في اليوم الذي كان من المفترض ان يتسلم
فيه الجمهوريون
زعمت مجلس النواب الامريكي ساد مشهد من
الفوضى وحاله من الانقسام في صفوفهم ففي
مشهد لم يتكرر منذ عام
1923 فشل مجلس النواب وتحديدا بسبب معارضه
20 جمهوريا من انتخاب رئيسا للمجلس بعد
ثلاث جولات من التصويت محصله هذه الجولات
الثلاثه وفي الاخيره منها تحديدا كان حصول
كابل مقاسي المرشح الابرز والذي قاد
الجمهوريين للحصول على الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب على 2002 صوتا فقط من اعضاء حزبه
مقابل 20 صوتا معارضا صوته لان نائب
الجمهوريه
كان بحاجه الى 2008 10 صوتا كي ااا يتزعم
ويتراس رئاسه مجلس النواب بالنسبه
لاديمقراطيين هذا المشهد مشهد الانقسام
هذا تركهم في وضع المتفرج ولكنهم كانوا
موحدين في صفوفهم بالتصويت بشكل متكرر
المئتين واثني عشر ديمقراطيا
لزعيمهم زعيم الاقليه الديمقراطيه حكيم
جافريز والان بعد اعلان مجلس النواب
تعليقه اعمال الى ان يتم ربما حدوث
انفراجه ما بين الجمهوريين المنقسمين على
انفسهم يبقى الان الوضع معلق دون رئيس
للمجلس مما يجمد ذلك اي اعمال داخل مجلس
النواب ان كان من حيث اداء الاعضاء اليمين
او القسم الدستوري ان كان من حيث تسير اي
تشريعات انتقاء من سيتراس
التشريعيه وامور اخرى مثلا ايضا كفتح
التحقيقات التي كان الجمهوريون قد وعدوا
بفتحها في اداره الرئيس بايدا ويضع هذا
كله تساؤلات عما اذا كان سيحدث انفراج
خلال
الساعات المقبله قبل انعقاد المجلس من
جديد
للحصول اوصول الى مرشح توافق يصوت عليه
جميع الجمهوريين وكيف سي ينعكس هذا
الانقسام على كيفيه تسير الجمهوريين
لحقنهم خلال العامين المقبلين اللذين الذي
يتراسون فيه مجلس النواب